questions andrew
thanks jamie and welcome to the press
conference
so the risks around the npc's forecasts
are
exceptionally large at present
the source of these risks and the driver
of most of the revisions to our
forecasts since the may report
is overwhelmingly
energy prices and the consequences of
the actions of russia
now in line with the conventions that we
use in the mpc
the baseline projections in the august
report are conditioned on wholesale
energy prices
following their futures curves for the
next six months and then remaining
constant
thereafter the path of bank rate implied
by financial markets
and fiscal policy evolving in line with
announced government policies
[Applause]
but there are a range of plausible paths
for the economy
which have cpi inflation and medium term
activity significantly higher or lower
than in the baseline projections
and with that in mind with the
uncertainty in mind that i referred to
in in the report we have included
several projections
for gdp unemployment and inflation
and a point i would draw out is that the
npc is currently placing less less
weight on the implications of any single
set of conditioning assumptions and
projections
choosing to draw more heavily on
alternative scenarios as well and again
consistent with the
uh point i made about uh uncertainty
now unlike some many recent press
conferences in view of this i thought it
would be helpful
as i go through my opening remarks to to
use some charts so you know there we are
you'll see some charts coming up uh
we'll also be publishing these charts as
well uh hopefully their reviews most of
them but not quite all of them by the
way are in the monetary policy report
but not quite all of them
now since they may report as this chart
shows the most significant piece of news
has been the further sharp increase in
energy prices you can see it in the
orange line
uh as against the purple line which is
the line from may
and
from that you can see we can see that
wholesale gas futures prices for the end
of this year
that's right at the hump that you see in
the orange line have nearly doubled
since may
moreover they're almost seven times
higher than implied by the futures curve
a year ago
and that's overwhelmingly a consequence
of russia's restriction of gas supplies
to europe
and the risk of further cuts
and you can see the when i talked about
the conditioning assumption and the the
way in which we hold the price constant
after six months you can see that from
the two dashed lines that appear on the
chart
the consequence of this is that
near-term inflationary pressures have
intensified significantly
cpi inflation is now expected to peak at
just over 13 percent in q4 of this year
and to remain at very elevated levels
throughout much of
2023 the bulk of that further increase
reflects higher wholesale prices feeding
through to retail energy prices with a
further large rise in the off-gen price
gap projected in october
and i should stress that our forecast
and our projections take into account
the new method
announced by off gem this morning
so you can see in the next chart the
direct impact of energy prices on cpi
inflation in our recent forecasts and
the extent of the latest upward
revisions the obviously the green line
i'll come back to the dash green line
later because that shows an alternative
projection which uses the the full
futures curve rather than the uh the
fixing of the of the line
but you can see that you can see
obviously very clearly what's gone on in
recent forecasts and i would emphasize
also i use very deliberately the word
direct impact of energy is of course
it's not the total impact of energy this
is the direct impact of energy
now this rise in energy prices has
exacerbated the fall in real incomes and
so led to another significant
deterioration in the outlook for
activity in the uk and in the rest of
europe
gdp growth in the uk has slowed and the
economy is now forecast to enter
recession later this year
as illustrated by the white line in this
chart and this chart is showing uh what
we're projecting and i'm using the
baseline projection here the the with
the with the fixed line of energy prices
and comparing it with past recessions
so the white line shows that the
projected peak to trough fall in output
of two and a quarter percent
would be similar to that experienced in
the early 1990s recession which is shown
in green if you
can see
although less than the global financial
crisis which is shown in pink
now in marked contrast to these previous
episodes this predominantly reflects the
adverse impact of the very sharp rising
global energy and tradable goods prices
on uk real income and spending
and as shown in the fan chart here for
inflation these developments have
further accentuated the extent to which
in the npc's baseline projection
uk cpi inflation is well above the 2
target over the first 18 months but well
below the target in three years time
cpi inflation is projected to fall back
somewhat from its peak to nine and a
half percent in a year's time
as rising domestic pressures are
outweighed by the assumed stabilization
of global energy prices and falls in
tradable goods prices
and inflation then falls sharply to the
two percent target in two years time as
external influences continue to
dissipate and domestic factors also fade
and then it falls well below the target
in three years time reflecting a further
weakening in domestic pressures
but going back to my introductory remark
the uncertainty around the outlook is
exceptionally high
especially for energy prices
under our standard conditioning
assumption energy prices would be
extremely high by historical standards
throughout the whole of the three year
forecast period and that's the effect of
fixing the of the price
as in recent reports we've also set out
an alternative projection in which
energy prices follow their downward
sloping futures curves over the forecast
period although they're still above
their pre-pandemic levels throughout
you can see that in this chart
now as shown in the the green to blue
line in this chart under this assumption
the lower contribution from energy
prices implies cpi inflation of around
one percentage point below the two
percent target at the two-year point and
even further below the target at year
three
this would result in a smaller fall in
households real incomes and spending and
gdp would be somewhat higher than in the
baseline projection
and you can see that here by looking at
the green line that has been put on
comparing it to the white line
the economy is still projected to
experience a recession but it's a less
deep one
the difference between these forecasts
demonstrates the sensitivity of the
outlook for inflation to swings in
energy prices because that's really the
only thing that changes here
the russian shock is now the largest
contributor to uk inflation by some way
there is an economic cost to the war
but i have to be clear it will not
deflect us from setting monetary policy
to bring inflation back to the two
percent target
now though responsible for much less of
the rise in headline inflation domestic
inflationary pressures have also
remained strong
firms generally report that they expect
to increase their selling prices
markedly
reflecting the sharp rise in their costs
the labour market remains tight
with the unemployment rate of 3.8
percent in the three months to may and
vacancies at historical high levels
tightness of the labour market partly
reflects the fall in the labor force
since the start of the pandemic
which is in part due to the large rise
in economic
inactivity shown by the orange bars in
this chart
as a result
and consistent with the latest agent
survey
underlying nominal wage growth is
expected to pick up further
domestic pressures on cpi inflation are
nevertheless expected to dissipate
thereafter
although the labour market may loosen
only slowly in response to falling
demand
unemployment is expected to rise from
next year
and with monetary policy acting to
ensure that longer-term inflation
expectations are anchored at the two
percent target
wage pressures are assumed to adjust
down quickly as inflation uh itself
falls back
there is however a risk that domestic
price setting proves more persistent
than in the mpc's baseline projection
and with that in mind the npr also
contains a scenario in which firms are
able to pass on the increases in their
labor costs to their prices to a greater
extent than normal
as shown in the purple line in this
chart under this scenario cpi inflation
is even further above the inflation
target at year two
but unchanged and still below target at
year three
so let me turn to the npc's decision
the mix of high near-term inflation and
weak activity leading up to a recession
is a challenging backdrop for monetary
policy
monetary policy must be set taking into
account the scale of the shock to real
income while keeping our focus on
inflation and inflation expectations
returning inflation to the two percent
target remains our absolute priority
there are no ifs or buts about that
at this meeting the committee voted to
increase bank rate by 0.5 percentage
points to 1.75
the committee judged that a more
forceful policy action was justified at
this meeting
as there have been some indications that
inflationary pressures are becoming more
persistent
and broadening to more domestically
driven sectors
companies are finding it easier to
increase prices and the labor market
remains tight
in such an environment there is a risk
that the further jump in energy prices
and the higher and more protracted path
for cpi inflation over the next 18
months will lead to more enduring
domestic price and wage pressures which
would be inconsistent with an inflation
returning to the two percent target
overall a faster pace of policy
tightening at this meeting will help to
bring inflation back to the two percent
target sustainably in the medium term
and to reduce the risks of a more
extended and costly tightening cycle
later
looking ahead that does not mean we are
now moving to a predetermined path of
raising bank rate by 50 basis points per
meeting or indeed any other number for
that matter
policy is not on a preset path
and what we do this time does not tell
you what we're going to do next time
all options are on the table for our
september meeting and beyond that
the mpc will take the necessary action
to return inflation to the two percent
target sustainably in the medium term in
line with a treatment
the scale pace and timing of any further
changes in bank rate will reflect the
committee's assessment of the economic
outlook and inflationary pressures
the committee will be particularly alert
to indications of more persistent
inflationary pressures
and will if necessary act forcefully in
response
i recognize the significant impact this
will have
and how difficult the cost of living
challenge will continue to be for many
people in the united kingdom
inflation hits the the least well-off
hardest
but if we don't act to prevent inflation
becoming persistent
the consequences later will be worse
and that will require larger increases
in interest rates
at this meeting the npc also provided an
update on its strategy for beginning to
sell the gilts held in our asset
purchase
facility portfolio
the npc is provisionally minded to
commence guilt sales shortly after its
september policy meeting subject to
economic and market conditions being
judged appropriate and took on to a
confirmatory vote therefore at that
meeting
where to precede the committee judge
that over the first 12 months of a sales
program a reduction in the stock of
purchase guilt held in the apf of around
80 billion pounds was likely to be
appropriate
given maturing guilt this would imply a
sales program of around 10 billion
pounds per quarter
the plan details of the proposed program
are set out in a market notice released
alongside the npr
so to conclude let me reiterate that our
job is to hit the inflation target and
in the current circumstances to return
inflation to target
to be clear there are no ifs or buts in
our commitments to the two percent
inflation target
that's our job and that's what we will
do
thank you
thanks very much and now uh for
questions if you wouldn't mind
identifying yourselves and your
organizations uh and please do speak up
and and speak directly into the
microphone sometimes hard
for us to hear try and stick to one
question uh first if that's okay and
then we'll we'll come around again joel
can we start with you
joel hill's itv news um
goodness where to start
um
if liz truss becomes prime minister
and implements a package of immediate
tax cuts
worth 30 billion pounds will it mean
governor that interest rates will have
to rise
faster and further than they otherwise
would
and connected to that liz trust has also
been explicitly critical of the bank
it's accused the bank of failing to grip
spiraling prices
do you accept that criticism and would a
different mandate have helped you keep
prices stable
well can i be very clear joel uh on two
points one is that it is not for the
bank of england to
get involved in the leadership election
is taking place
for the leader of the conservative party
the next prime minister we're not going
to comment
on that
secondly as i said earlier we condition
on the fiscal policy that is announced
i look forward to working with whoever
the next prime minister is and i'm sure
there will be a budget and fiscal policy
will be announced but at this stage i'm
not going to go any further than that in
uh commenting on what might or might not
happen
so i'd loosen it
hi i'm lucy white from the daily mail um
going back to uh joel's question um
obviously liz trust has spoken about
wanting to alter the bank of england's
mandate do you think there is room for a
change and um
would you welcome uh any suggestions
um and also obviously we're looking at a
pretty dire picture for households um
income falling for the next two years
um
the largest amount on records um
in
plain speaking terms
how bad does this look for the uk i mean
obviously the obr's projections for
the public finances over the long term
were pretty bad already
um if
the next prime minister does introduce
you know further further support
packages for households
how bad is it going to get
well again i'm going to say to joel i'm
not going to comment on uh anything that
is being said by the candidates to the
leader of the conservative party
i i'll say two things one
just to remind what the mandate of the
bank of england is in respect of uh
monetary policy
and that is that the objective set out
in statute it was set out in 1997 is
price stability
and that each year the government in the
form of the chancellor
informs us what price stability i'll use
the language of the act is taken to be
in other words the government sets the
target
and it's important to make that point
because it's that's that's a somewhat
different structure to many other
countries now i'm not saying that that
in any judgmental sense that's that's
what it is i think the great you know
the great virtue of our system it is
very clear what the target is
but i also make the point that the
structure the structure was set up
with a very clear mandate of price
stability
but there is scope obviously and and
then the mandate has sorry the target
has been changed once over the lifetime
of the mpc with the change of uh a
definition of cpi
um there have also been reviews from
time to time
now on the second question i'm not going
to comment on on again on fiscal policy
i all i would
emphasize in terms of the situation just
to reinforce the remarks i made is that
the
consequences of the actions that have
followed and emanate from russia
are obviously serious as you could tell
from the remarks i made and
our decision and the npr
dave do you want to come can i just
think of a bit more detail um on
the you know there has been a previous
review of the monetary policy framework
it was carried out by the coalition
government in
2013.
um i mean the only other point that i'd
mention is that if you you know it's
just been 25 years since the mpc was
established so if you take the average
cpi inflation rate bearing in mind as
andrew just said that cpi became the
target in 2003 but take the average cpi
inflation rate from may 1997
to april um 2022 it's it's averaged
almost exactly two percent which is the
inflation target
i've got marine and then paul
uh hello uh mehreen khan from the times
over here um governor you've spoken for
the last few months about the need to
tread a narrow path between managing
inflation and growth do these forecasts
show that actually you will abandon that
narrow path and you will have to tighten
monetary policy in the face of a
severely uh a sharply uh shrinking
economy um
and when was the last time the bank has
really been put into that position thank
you
sorry and that's the last part of it
when is
what are the political pressures that
come with having to tighten monetary
policy in the face of a severely um
contracting economy
well i'll tell you the universe i'm sure
ben will want to come in actually on
this and can i say that you know one of
the great strengths of being an
independent central bank is that
actually you know the political
pressures have been very well managed
throughout the life of the mpc in my
view and obviously we've had many
governments throughout that life
and you know that is the best way to
manage it in my view so no no i don't
really want to put emphasis on political
pressures because
you know i think one of the great
virtues of our system is that the bank
of england takes these decisions
independently
um respecting of course the importance
of the remit i i'll bring ben in but i
just want to say on the narrow path no i
don't think the narrow path analogy has
been abandoned at all i think if
anything this illustrates
and what we've seen happen since we were
last sitting here in the beginning of
may
um when i know we also talked about the
narrow path is i mean i don't know
whether the analogy is right to say it's
got narrower it's got you know
it's got the slopes on either side have
got steeper i'm not going to sickly
speculate on what the right analogy is
at this point
but the general the generals in a sense
framework of analysis of the narrow path
is is i think
as relevant today as it was then and i
would by the way
you know i think it's it's an analogy
that's not unique to us it's used by a
number of other central banks as well
who are facing somewhat similar
situations ben did you want
yes they certainly are um
i think
what is true of the current situation
regardless of that particular analogy is
that we are facing and have for some
time been facing these ever increasing
trade-off inducing shocks to use the
slightly form formal terminology
of the mpc
they are intrinsically shocks which in
the near term push up inflation but also
weaken growth
and that combination is unavoidable it's
one that you see throughout the world
certainly this year
we already had those shocks occurring
last year as a result of the pandemic
so in non-energy and core goods prices
it feels like a long time ago now in
2021 we experienced very steep increases
and most of those we import
so qualitative but they had a similar
effect
they reduced real incomes even as they
pushed up
uh near-term inflation
the scale of the
shocks induced by the war
and the restrictions of gas supplies
have been even steeper and to give you
an idea quite how you asked about
history
quite how big they are it's worth
comparing the effects on
households utility bills
uh during the current episode
with the 1970s which was another period
in which energy prices went up steeply
so over the worst two-year period of the
70s
which i think was between the first
quarters of 1974 and 76
the share of income going on household
utility bills rose by i think 0.7
percentage points so it's absorbed that
much of real income growth over that
period
between the first two first quarters of
2021
and 2023
we think that number will be
pretty much three and a half percentage
points there's around five times as big
so that is the scale of just the energy
price shock and on top of that you have
what happened as a result of the
pandemic last year
and other effects of the war for example
on wholesale
traded food prices
sticking with the picking up slightly on
what we heard a moment ago
about monetary policy
you know it's our job
navigating that trade-off
absolutely to ensure
that these shocks as enormous as they
are
do not persist
via more domestic inflationary pressure
longer than they should
they will regrettably be with us for a
while looking at a path of
of energy prices
but we will make sure that they are not
there in the inflation rate in two three
years time and we'll do whatever
necessary whatever is necessary to to
ensure that's the case and that will be
one big difference
between this shop much larger though it
is
and what happened uh
in historical episodes in particular the
70s and 80s
thanks i've got
paul then august and gemini
paul kelso sky news governor you talk
about a great deal of uncertainty
in your models particularly around
energy prices but are there any
scenarios you've looked at that are not
catastrophic
for the least well-off in society and
pretty devastating even for average
earners in the next couple of years
well you make a very important point
paul and we've you know we've talked
about this in the past but it's
important to re-emphasize it that
energy that inflation that is
concentrated amongst what we might call
the essentials
in consumption baskets obviously of
which energy is a very important part of
food is another important part of that
hits those those who are least well off
and have lowest incomes the hardest and
you can see this by looking at the
different consumption baskets across
deciles of household income and the uh
in the household survey
so we you know we're we're very
conscious of this and i you know i said
in my opening remarks you know this is
this is this is a very uncomfortable
situation to be in
with very aware of the impact it has
there on those who are least well off
what i would emphasize or re-emphasize
is a point i made in my opening remarks
and it's this
if we don't bring inflation back to
target
bearing in mind this huge scale of the
energy shock we're seeing if we don't
bring it back to target
and if we get these so-called
second-round effects entering in it's
going to get worse
and it will get worse precisely i'm
afraid for those who are least well-off
in society
so while i have a huge sympathy and you
know huge understanding for those who
are struggling most with this
and i know that they will feel well you
know why have you raised interest rates
today doesn't that make it worse from
that perspective in terms of consumption
i'm afraid my side is it doesn't because
i'm afraid the alternatives is even
worse
in terms of persistent inflation
august and gemini
hello um
so
in this latest forecast inflation set to
peak at 13.3 percent in october and
that's based on a uh prediction that the
price capital right raise rise by about
to about 3 450.
um but the latest price cap predictions
has um the cap at nearly
3950 by january um do you feel there's a
risk that inflation will peak above that
october forecast at any point next year
sorry
you've predicted in october
at any point next year well i mean
you know our view on as we've said in
the report is that we
think on the basis of what off-gem have
told us that the price
cap setting for october will be around
three and a half thousand pounds
um
obviously
beyond that and by the way i mean as you
know the i'm sure you know the the
methodology that off gem have adopted
means that the window is not closed yet
as it would have been under the previous
methodology so there's
there's an element of sort of still to
be determined but it's not obviously not
a very large element but there is i
think beyond that of course it becomes
less easy to predict because it depends
on movements in uh in in future price
fighters and we've seen from the charts
they move you know
they're moving around a lot at the
moment so we're harder to predict
we set out in quite a lot of detail um
in the monetary policy report
you know the risks around
that inflation projection
there is
we do have a skew on our inflation
projection and upside skew in the first
year that re which relates directly to
the calculation of cpi
because that gets re-weighted every year
to take account of the consumption
basket
and then more qualitatively
we flag the risks
um as andrew has
said you know were inflation to be more
persistent
than than we are now assuming then that
would give you
further um upside risks but overall
actually
we think the risks to inflation are
balanced after year one so we don't have
a skew in our forecasts after year one i
think that's that's right there is a bit
of i mean there is another downsides
potential downside risk which is
dependent on how the ons
uh treats the and already announced uh
elements of the of the government
support package
um so there are risks both ways on
energy i would say yeah
thank you
jimana then larry
gimana versace from cnbc i have a
question about the term act forcefully
you've kept it in the monetary policy
statement today
and
it was in there in june and translated
today to a 50 basis point hike
my question is about what new
information you would need to see to opt
for another 50 basis points hike in
september
well
let me be clear that
um
we make policy meeting by meeting
we will see what uh what information
obviously comes in between now and the
september meeting and of course
information will come in
it's very important to my mind that we
move
and i have moved from what i would call
a system of
more sort of predictive forward guidance
to a framework that is not productive
it's designed to
to convey our senses to the framework
within which we make decisions
and so it's very important that you know
the act forcefully language is still
there
because the reason is that if we see
evidence
that you know we think justifies that
then i think it's important that people
understand that's what we would do
um
if you ask me um
the question which i think you were sort
of moving to which is
what are you particularly looking at at
the moment
um well i think i would as well as
pointing obviously to what's going on in
the external environment i would go back
to the points i made in the sort of
latter part of my remarks
um which we pick up
quite extensively not only from the
surveys but also i would say you know
all three of us go around the country
talking to businesses and
how we do a lot of that that's
notwithstanding the
evidence that there was there is slowing
a slowing demand going on economy of
course notwithstanding the forecast that
we have
um
businesses at the moment as our agents
tell us still feel that they you know
they could they can set prices
you know to recover the increase in
costs
uh and they're not meeting a lot of
resistance on that so that's an
important part of the
uh you know the diagnosis and the sort
of the yeah the evidence assessment that
we do and we'll continue to do i mean it
hasn't i emphasize it because
you know it has a high profile at the
moment and needs to have a high profile
at the moment because of course it goes
directly to this question of persistence
thanks and i've got quite a lot on the
list but don't worry we will get to you
can i have larry and then fires all
please
larry elliott of the guardian a year ago
you were forecasting inflation would
peak at four percent now you're
predicting it will peak at
13.3 percent
you say some of that higher inflationary
pressure is becoming embedded in the
economy and that's why you're being
forced to raise rates by 50 basis points
rather than 25 basis points your critics
say
that having been asleep at the wheel the
bank is now slamming on the brakes at
precisely the wrong time
they have a point don't they
no i don't think they do but let me put
it's a point that obviously needs to be
responded to um
so as i said at the mansion house
recently we've been hit
the world economy has been hit by very
big shocks
and in the for the uk that means very
big external shocks
moreover there have been no what i would
call air gaps between these shocks so if
you think about the you know the covid
supply chain shock
which we now begin to see evidence in
terms of traded goods prices of it
beginning to come off that has been
replaced by this you know this huge
shock that we're receiving in terms of
energy prices
uh and obviously emanating from the
actions that russia is taking
and you know i think has to be clear
that the bank of england cannot
you know forecast and i don't know
anybody who reasonably can say they
could have forecast a ukrainian war a
year ago
so that is a very important rebuttal to
the point larry
the second thing i would say is that
the point on
uh the bank of england taking action
sometimes then goes to the question of
quantitative easing
you know did we do too much uh during
the covet crisis
and
my response to that is as follows i
think if you you know to sustain that
argument
you really have to make the argument
that domestic demand in the uk
uh has risen uh you know substantially
uh as we came out of covid
and that is simply just not the case i
mean what we've had in the uk is a
situation where
gdp
you know has just about
got above its pre-covered level but only
just and of course if you take the
forecast that we're presenting today
that is not going to be sustained
and what has actually happened is that
we've had a series of supply shots going
back to my point about global shock so
you know it's just it's up to sum up i i
don't accept that argument i'm afraid
andrew you're coming back
with a couple of
numbers you mentioned the peak
the forecast peak a year ago
and what it is today and in his opening
remarks the governor
pointed out a that between those two
times
the wholesale price of gas the one
forward price for the end of this year
has gone up sevenfold
and that just the direct effects of that
increase in energy prices
would be six and a half percentage
points on inflation checking the direct
effects and you're getting to the vast
majority of the increase in the forecast
earlier even that four percent a lot of
it was due to external shocks of the
kind i was describing earlier that
happened to be non-energy due to the
pandemic
it's a marginal thing now relative to
what we've seen in in energy prices but
it is actually the case as we thought it
would be
a year ago that some of those increases
in core goods prices are now beginning
to stabilize or even to reverse
and there's a bit of that in the report
and that's why at that time
and indeed throughout the last year we
were not responding directly to these
external shocks enormous as though there
been because what we're interested in is
will they persist
will they be there by the time a policy
decision get taken now
has a significant bearing on inflation
that's the relevant thing
and that's what we've been responding to
the signs
of more domestically driven inflation
now they're much smaller they're far
smaller than those headline rates but
that's what we're responding to because
that's what we want to ensure doesn't
remain in inflation in
a year
two years time
in order to have kept inflation let's
suppose that we'd had this extraordinary
foresight
to see the continuing
pandemic restrictions on supply in asia
throughout last year
more importantly to foresee
russia's invasion of ukraine
and then ask what would have been
necessary
to have done possessed of that foresight
let's say we'd seen everything all of
this at the tail end of 2020 which has
given the lags
what we needed to have had that force in
order to
hit the inflation target right now and
offset all the effects of that on
inflation right now
interest rates in order to offset that
would certainly have been i mean miles
into double-digit territory and we would
have had a far bigger recession even the
one we're forecasting now and nominal
income growth would have to have been
steeply negative
so that's what would have been
required
after the event you can say well
you should have done x y and z i'm
really saying and i agree with the
governor that foreseeing a lot of these
events i mean no one did
and we are focused now
as we should be
on
you know the potential spillovers on
domestic inflation and making sure these
things don't persist
uh but i don't think it would have been
possible
uh without enormous foresight to have
responded to them in time to have any
effect on their
on inflation contemporaneously and
furthermore to have done so would surely
have involved a bigger downturn even
than one we're forecasting
okay i've got faisal and nc
uh thanksgiving bbc in the past your
predecessors have when we've faced with
a kind of market shock maybe sterling
falling have chosen to look through some
of that inflation coming up knowing that
i'll wash out of the figures eventually
i just wondered if any consideration had
been given to the fact that this is not
just a sort of market shock it's kind of
like a conscious geopolitic political
tactic arguably from the kremlin to push
up prices of energy and food and whether
you know
a normal market responses is is is the
right response in those circumstances
and a related question would be just
explain simply to somebody at home who's
facing 300 pound a month energy bills
why their mortgage costs have to go up
yeah so i think the first question
faisal really picks up what ben was
saying um uh uh a minute or two ago in
that as he said
you know
there is there is an established
monetary policy response
that you you know you do look through
the so-called first-round effects
whereas ben was saying you can see that
they are not going to go beyond the
horizon of the reaction of monetary
policy
and nothing has changed in that respect
i mean the word transient has become i
know something of a sort of damaged
phrase but the underlying concept has
not changed
so the
challenge we have is
that this is a very large shock
and we've had to spend a lot of time
going back what i was saying a few
moments ago
assessing
what are the likely second round effects
of that which is that's where we have to
sort of concentrate
what are the risks that it will give way
to you know price setting domestic price
setting
uh domestic wage setting
which will then cause persistent
inflation now you know the evidence of
that you know there's there's a lot of
things that we've looked at um you know
and by the way of course
that sort of evidence does emerge with a
lack
there are natural lags in the system
but we've seen things particularly as
i've made set out in my opening remarks
in terms of what we're seeing in terms
of price setting
um
and of course what that implies for the
ability to pass on costs of all sorts
which do concern us frankly do concern
us um there's a bit of a sort of two
views of the world here there's a view
that you can see from our forecast which
is as we've been discussing is a
you know it's it's not a good story
there is an economy with the moment
which is still going forward strongly
and by the way you know particularly in
the labour markets i mean i wouldn't
emphasize the labor market here when i
talk to firms like when we all talk to
firms their concern is still how do we
hire enough people
and that they are not hitting
the sort of price pressures and price
resistance that
i'm afraid i think they will hit
eventually but it's not coming yet and
that's the risk of persistence and
that's why we have to act
on the second part of your question
again very important and i'd really go
back to the question i answered earlier
on this and say
if we don't act now
and i realized
how difficult this is i realized as we
were saying for particularly for those
those on lower incomes particularly
those with higher borrowing uh costs
but if we don't act
inflation will become more embedded it
will get worse and we will have to raise
interest rates by more and that yeah we
have to act to prevent to stop that
i have two then dave robinson then
ashley
[Music]
hi su chan from the telegraph um
governor we've had six rate rises in a
row now in your opinion are high street
banks passing on those rate rises to
savers as much as they have been to
borrowers and if not
does that make your job harder
so i think the evidence suggests that
the pass-through has been uh faster to
to borrowers than it has been to save us
so far
and you'll have seen by the way we
publish of course monetary statistics
which um
which allow you to look at that
um
i am conscious that
when rates fell to very low levels i
mean obviously we're going back now sort
of 14 13 14 years
there were some issues about the
relationship between the official rate
and saving rates which got out of line
with some of their sort of previous
practices and we may see some you know
some reversal of that going on but what
i would say and i think this is very
important is that it is of course
important that uh savers receive uh
receive the returns that they should
receive
now one of the reasons that we have
worked and are working will continue to
work to introduce ensuring short
competition in the banking system is
exactly so that sort of thing
that sort of thing happens so we you
know it is something that we watch like
very carefully it's something other
authorities watch very carefully because
there are you know there are a lot of
responsibilities there too
if i can just add is
we've i mean we we always focus on this
in the monetary policy report we have
set out in detail
in box d of the report
the the extent have passed through and
it is clear that um at the moment as
table one there shows i mean the pass
through
after the kind of pretty unusual period
we were in as andrew was saying pass
through onto
onto borrowing rates has been material
and in line with the the relevant
reference rates whereas um pass through
on to saving rates has not been so far
they have started to move up if you look
at you know instant access deposit
accounts which are the most
the most common but those have only
risen by 30 basis points since november
2021 whereas the
you know just before we started raising
bank rate whereas over that period the
relevant reference rate had risen by 115
basis points so
but one would expect over time
some you know some closing i would
imagine of that
well no i think from where we are now
it's you know we can we can we can
understand where it's at now but it's
something that you know we will continue
to monitor
and it's also something that just as
you're raising i imagine will continue
to be in the in the public debate
because it is obviously important that
savers
and and savings products
are seen to be representative
dave robinson and then ashley
thanks
dave robinson market news
you said you take fiscal policy as given
for very understandable reasons
the concern of some city economists is
okay but the market curve assumes
further fiscal stimulus
we know the risks of more stimulus are
very high there is less stimulus near
zero so that makes it a bias forecast
market curve is conditioned on more
stimulus
how do you stop the problem of this all
becoming a little incoherent
well i mean also i think
ben dave may both want to come in i
think i think it's a it's a form of an
issue that we face always we condition
our forecasts on the market curve
um
now
there are good reasons for doing that
but we also we always as you rightly say
have to recognize and accept that the
market curve will embody of course all
sorts of um expectations
some of which are in line with the way
in which we construct our forecasts and
some which are some of which are not um
the market may have views on future
fiscal policy and may embody those
we condition the rest of our forecast on
on what the government has announced you
know it's going to do until such time as
the government announces it's going to
do something else
um
what i would i would say is that is one
another reason why you know
the forecast or forecasts and
projections as we have today
are important inputs to the policy
making process but you know we spend
time i think consistent with your line
of diagnosis saying well you know
what what do we read into this where
where should we sort of aim off a bit
because you know we might imagine there
may be
something going on and we of course the
market curve therefore of course is not
i should stress
our view of what's going to happen in
the future we don't we don't actually
create our own curve
um
but yeah we're not we're not saying you
know the market curve is the view of the
future it's a view of the future which
we use there is a second one of course
which is again is another one you can
take which is the one we now publish in
our uh
in our maps survey um
but again you know that will also have
all you know all sorts of assumptions
embedded in it as well
yes i mean that you know it's not the
only view of the future as andrew says
and when we survey market participants
their predictions are not in line with
the market curve either presumably they
too will have thought about all sorts of
possible futures including different
fiscal policy
there have been occasions when
i think of one in particular
when
we were able to identify very clearly
something that was affecting market
prices but was not in our forecast and
that was on the eve of the eu referendum
when by assumption by conditioning
assumption we said there was zero chance
of a leave vote the market was putting
some weight on that possibility
and we said well here's what the world
would look like if the exchange rate
were actually in line with our
conditioning assumption at zero and we
did a forecast on that basis so there
are occasions when we make
try and make adjustments
as andrew says i think when we're
thinking about actual policy
we don't necessarily think rigidly about
the central forecast
and as illustrated by the range of
scenarios or lots of different forecasts
we think about all sorts of possible
futures and it's the responsibility of
each member of the npc to think how he
or she would weight those in coming to a
policy decision
but we face this in various forms all
the time i don't think there's a better
way of doing the forecast but it does
have this
this potential inconsistency within it
and look i think the key thing here is
that we're transparent about the
assumptions
and and you so you can see what the
moving parts are
uh the markets can see what's going on
and as as andrew was emphasizing in his
opening remarks yeah we always we always
publish a constant path scenario
um and this time we've gone further you
know in line with those very other
possible futures around energy price
assumptions or persistence with with
with more alternative projections
okay i've got uh ashley philip escher
and then bill would we'll definitely get
through those if we're quick enough and
then we'll then we'll see ashley first
hi ashley armstrong from the sun um a
few months ago you used the word
apocalyptic to describe the rising feed
prices now it's getting to 13.1
inflation what word would you use
um and then secondly you asked for
people to show restraint when asking for
wage increases given that most of or the
majority of that inflation is actually
coming from russia's invasion of ukraine
do you regret telling people that they
should be restrained and asking for pay
rises
well
the food situation
it was very serious
um and of course remains very serious
um
you know many of the i go to many
international meetings um a g7 g20 and
there's no question that when you went
to those meetings
there were very great concerns about the
situation in world food supply
i mean the good news is i think there's
several pieces of good news actually you
know food commodity prices haven't on on
balance come down
over the last few months and
unfortunately the gas prices of course
more than overwhelmed it going the other
way but food prices have come down
and i think that reflects a number of
things it reflects the fact that
actually um you know there's been some
quite good news on crop potential crop
yields in other parts of the world
which will which will somewhat
compensate for the ukrainian problem and
of course we've all got you know
we're all hoping that the you know the
ship that left odessa this week will be
the first of uh first of many uh
and that too will of course provide much
needed relief
we have to watch it very clearly i mean
food is another element of the inflation
story here we've put a lot of emphasis
on energy because it's the big one but
uh food is another almonds on your
points about wages i mean i mean make it
clear
what i said was that you know if
people perceive very high wage increases
then
you know we will have these second round
effects and we will get persistent
inflation
let me let me also say i mean the
question i was asked didn't included but
as you'll see from what i said in the
opening remarks today because that also
includes price increases as well because
you can't
obviously take these two apart
and we remain concerned about as we said
earlier about this this question of
persistence and the question of the the
role of domestic price setting and how
you know that could that could play a
part in it
but i want to emphasize this point about
high wage increases it wasn't any wage
increase it was high wage increases now
i would note that quite a few other
people seem to have you know made that
remark also in the intervening period
i want to finish by just going back to
points i've made quite a few times since
then and i'll make it again because it
goes back to an earlier question
another reason why we have to be
concerned about this is precisely the
point the right has been made by a
number of other questions a number of
other questions that it is the least
well-off
who get hit hard it's by this and it's
the least well-off who have the least
labour bargaining power typically
and you know i would just emphasize that
point
thanks um i have
philip and then
uh
try and get through as many as we can
yeah we'll we'll try and give shorter
answers and
he wouldn't be the one saying that's a
virtue
hi it's bill schoenberg hopefully it
should be a short question and a short
answer um you say that the npc is now
ready to crack home of guilt sales after
the september meeting but that's going
to be subject to economic and market
conditions being judged appropriate
has there been any point this year when
those market conditions were not
appropriate are they appropriate now for
example um
when was the last time they were
inappropriate and what are you looking
at to judge the appropriateness of the
market conditions for selling guilt well
i'll get dave to answer it i mean i'll
give you an easy answer one part of your
question is that on
march the
15th
2020 they were inappropriate
dave
yes so
um
what you've drawn attention to is one of
the
you know three key principles that we've
set out in the minutes for
um you know that will frame our strategy
for asset sales
and the second of those principles is
that sales will be conducted so as not
to disrupt the functioning of financial
markets
and clearly back in
march 2020
financial markets were in such a
position that we would not have
gone ahead with sales
i mean we we track um what is going on
in core financial markets particularly
in the gilt market very carefully as you
would expect us to
and we will continue to do that but what
i think it's really important
that we do is not get into some kind of
uh running commentary on on where you
know where the market has got to
we did though say in the minutes and i
think you know
this comes back to the example that
andrew gave that there would be a high
bar for amending the planned reduction
in the stock of purchase gilts we'd
you know it would we need to be
we'd need to be seeing i mean we use the
language in the minutes that say that
markets were judged would need to be
judged to be
very stressed
before we considered halting the program
so um
but we also
emphasize that the mp the sorry the fpc
which we're all also a member of would
have a role in
looking at those kind of issues because
after all it's responsible for the
assessment of financial stability and
the fpc was front and center back in
march 2020
when we had very difficult market
conditions
since march 2020 no i know i didn't say
that i didn't say that i just gave you
that example and but we track
market conditions very carefully
philip and then uh
yeah philippines from the observer um
i'm still confused and ben andrew um
after everything you've said about
domestically driven inflation and the
effect of interest rates on it um it
still seems to be a very small
proportion of the inflation that we're
going to see
and an awful lot of what comes down over
the next two years is because those
factors start to wane nothing to do with
domestic
inflation could you explain what the
proportion of uh domestic inflation is
in your rise and therefore why it's not
the case that you're using a
sledgehammer to crack a nut
you're right that it's a minority of the
current inflation and certainly as a
minority of the
peak
the vast majority of these
global prices
and in particular the ones that have
been sensitive
uh to the war but they they're not the
whole of it
and nor would i describe what we're
doing as a sledgehammer
uh it's true that rates have gone up
you know every meeting
had now gone up
over an eight-month period since we
started by more than any similar
eight-month horizon
npc has faced
but i think it would be surprising
it would have been surprising and we
started to discuss the potential for
these second round effects i have to say
a year ago when we were looking even
then at what was smaller energy price
increases if there had been none
uh
if it was not the case in this face of
what amounts to an enormous hit
external hit to the real incomes
of
you know the economy as a whole
certainly the non-north sea economy
i think it was to be expected that to
some degree
households would want to protect their
real incomes by asking for more pay and
firms would want to protect their real
profits by seeking compensatory rises in
their own prices now we've seen far less
of that
i would argue because of the monetary
regime we have
than we did in earlier decades despite
what was a much bigger shock but we have
seen some
so the governor mentioned some results
from our decision maker panel survey
what we're picking up from the agents
it's been true for some time i think
that a part of you can detect in rates
of wage growth
a part of the increase in wages that is
due not just to the tight labor market
but the fact of these second round
effects and quite understandably people
seeking some compensation because these
external hits have been so
vast i wouldn't describe what we've done
as a sledgehammer i would describe it as
an appropriate response
to what we're seeing in that respect to
the signs of more domestic inflation
and i would only emphasize
what the governor said right at the
start
you know it is
critical it is our job to make sure
these things don't persist because we
know that
high and variable inflation over
years
over the medium to longer term
are not good for the economy
and that is why we're having to act so
it is the right thing to do the last
thing i'd say is just to emphasize
in a way the point you started with
which is the relative scale of these
things
and the huge scale of the energy price
head
we've given various forecasts
in particular as we normally do we give
them one based on the market profile for
interest rates and another based on
assuming they stay at what is now
today's level
even had they been
at one and a quarter percent even had
they stayed at yesterday's level
throughout my guess is the forecast
would still have had a recession in it
so
it is in the nature of the shock
it is in the nature of the scale of the
shock unfortunately
that it pushes up inflation enormously
for a period and that it depresses
activity and incomes that is that is
unavoidable
and our job is to make sure that we
absolutely don't allow this persistence
even though these second round effects
are
to a degree entirely understandable we
have to act
to ensure they don't persist
if you know what i'm saying i'm just
going to observe putting your question
hilarious question together
the because it's in the nature that we
have to make forward-looking judgments
and you know you're saying well aren't
you sort of taking a sledgehammer to
crack something that today looks like a
nut and we're saying well it might not
be a nut in the future and we're worried
about it and larry's saying while you
were asleep at the wheel in the past i
mean this is the nature of the judgments
we have to make
okay we're going to run five minutes
over so that we can do
and then
delphine and then francine and then then
we'll see
hi easton nelson from the new york times
i'm away from energy prices which
obviously you've said many times in the
past you can't do anything about um
you've noted that there are some aspects
of inflation that look to be easing so
global commodity prices aren't going up
anymore the median term inflation
expectations are lowering so how and was
you have this huge recession forecast
was there any pressure to move at 50 to
act forcibly so that you didn't feel out
of out of step with your international
peers where they're moving 50 75 one
percentage point to avoid you know an
impact on the exchange rate to avoid
questions about your credibility um and
to have this kind of stronger more
forceful even though most of this is the
short-term energy price increase yeah
that's a good question so thanks i mean
i've said before of course that yeah we
don't target the exchange rate we we
obviously factor in the impact of the
exchange rates into our judgements on on
future inflation that's exactly what
we've done this time
um i think the point i'd make about
comparing you know across central banks
is that each of us is facing you know a
different configuration of shops you
know i've said before that if you look
at the bank of england the federal
reserve and the ecb we've got elements
in common and we've got very different
elements
to it and so the fact that i think you
know the federal reserve is actually
you know raising by larger amounts i
think you can explain that i can
certainly rationalize that in terms of
the different
shocks that we're facing i think that
there's more of a there is more of a
domestic demand story in the us than
there is here
um uh and so i you know i think that's
how i rationalize the different
approaches i think you know each of us
because we're independent
we're responding to the economies that
we serve
are taking these decisions and it's you
know it's natural that those decisions
will have elements of commonality
but they will also be different
uh so i you know i think it's important
when people say well you know you should
be doing well there's other central
banks doing all that other central banks
doing
you know my always my response to that
is you know we look very carefully at
the shocks that we're facing
but we also of course look very
carefully the shocks that other central
banks are facing a to understand
how they're responding but be of course
in many cases because we're an open
economy they are affecting
uh they're affecting our situation as
well but yeah but we do serve the
domestic inflation it's domestic
inflation that we are targeting
so we have been listening to a press
conference there with the governor of
the bank of england andrew bailey giving
us his uh forecast as we get the news
that interest rates are going to be
raised by half a percentage point to
1.75 percent and a pretty bleak outlook
in terms of inflation and also a
recession being forecast i also want to
get you up to date with some comments
that have just come in from the
chancellor nadim zahawi on the back of
course of all this news that's broken
the last hour he has said along with
many other countries in the uk is facing
global economic challenges i know that
these forecasts will be concerning for
many people he then goes on to say i'm
confident that the actions that we are
taking means we can also overcome these
global challenges the very latest
they're from nadim zahaween
live now to the bank of england our
business correspondent paul kelso as you
saw him asking a question in that press
conference and now giving us his
analysis and a pretty bleak outlook paul
yeah it is and it was striking that the
governor didn't try to disguise that and
he began the presentation we've just
been watching by setting out the major
driver of the inflationary forces that
the bank is trying to
address with this interest rate rise by
mapping out the
increase in energy prices wholesale gas
prices which are driving inflation in
the uk and around the world i was struck
by a couple of things one that he was
attempting when asked by me and others
to empathize very squarely with the
people this will affect the most we have
the low those on the lowest incomes uh
in the uk already facing this huge
energy price shock those of whom who
have borrowing that might be tracking
the bank of england's
base rate are now going to find their
cost of living hit by another increase
the biggest single month increase in 30
years and he said
he realizes that this hits those on the
lowest incomes those who can least
afford it the hardest but his
justification was very clear and
repeated several times if they don't act
now it will get worse and in the long
term interest rates will have to get
higher and that will hurt even more so
the message essentially is this is going
to hurt but it's necessary paying for
the economy and for individuals
for the plan as the bank sees it to try
and raise interest rates just enough to
keep a cap on
lasting inflation in check so that when
the external huge inflationary pressure
of gas prices does recede hopefully does
recede over the next year or two the
economy here is not saddled with
inflation above the target of two
percent that's a very narrow uh road
that the bank has to walk and he says
it's still the right path he did say
that the uh the sides have got a little
steeper the consequences of falling if
you like have got worse always strike
also striking that he was asked
immediately about some of the policies
put forward by the conservative
leadership contenders who will hear from
on sky news this evening liz trust the
favorite at the moment
has put forward tax rises at the very
centre of her policy platform and
there's also been some noise from those
around her about the bank of england's
role and whether it has done the right
thing whether it is in some ways
responsible for some of this economic
gloom by acting too slowly and by some
of the other
issues and some of the other things it
did around quantitative easing to try
and stimulate the economy well he
steered very very clear of any of that
he wouldn't be drawn at all on what he
called the politics he wouldn't comment
on whether tax rises would be
inflationary or any of the platform that
they're set up that's probably wise if
you're the governor of the bank of
england but it it was striking and at
the end there
to finish he he again emphasized there
is there will be questions if all this
inflationary pressure is external is
because bluntly vladimir putin and our
attempts to ease ourselves off russian
gas why do we need to raise interest
rates why do we need to make things
harder for the for uk consumers and
households who are already incredibly
hard pressed under this forecast they'll
be facing the worst cost of living
reduction or forgive me
the worst um real terms decline in
living standards
since the 1960s why make that worse and
it's very clear he and his advisors his
colleagues on the mpc that if they don't
act now we will be left with residual
inflation if you like that will be
higher than the economy should bear so
it's an attempt to try and act pretty
aggressively now
possibly with similarly high uh
increases to interest rates in future
they said they weren't guaranteed the
idea is that will emerge from this in a
better position than would otherwise
otherwise be the case but it's a
judgment call and we'll all ultimately
feel the consequences of how right
they've got it
paul we'll leave it there for now thank
you very much paul kelso outside the
bank of england for us and of course
more reaction to for you throughout the
course of programme here on sky news
but uh first this lunchtime will
certainly bring you more this lunch time
the family of archie battersby have told
sky news that they're expecting a high
court hearing half past three this
afternoon after they launched a bid to
have him moved out of hospital and into
a hospice the twelve-year-old's mother
said earlier that she prays the court
will do the right thing after their
final legal battle to prevent his life
support being withdrawn failed last
night archie battersby has been in a
coma since april after being found
unconscious by his mother their home in
south end in essex
while in june a judge first ruled that
archie's life support treatment should
stop with doctors saying it was highly
likely that he was brain stem dead
archie's parents disputed this they were
given permission to appeal against the
ruling at the court of appeal
judges there then ruled that archie's
case should be reconsidered at the high
court that judge ruled that doctors
could lawfully stop providing life
support treatment saying its
continuation would delay the inevitable
after appeals from archie's parents the
united nations requested that the 12
year old would be kept alive while it
considered his case
but the supreme court dismissed the
family's application to appeal the
decision to remove life support with
treatment due to be withdrawn yesterday
morning
the family then applied to the european
court of human rights to intervene but
it said it would not interfere with
previous rulings by national courts
and after making an application to the
high court this morning the family's
application to move archie to a hospice
will